un mariage qui dure depuis dix ans le
paris-nice partira une nouvelle fois
depuis les yvelines a prêché et où
l'année dernière saint germain en laye a
été retenue comme ville départ de cette
67e édition
les coureurs partiront le dimanche 10
mars du parc du château pour une grande
boucle de 130 8 5 km à travers les
imminent passant notamment par touahri
montfort l'amaury ou encore poissy
pourquoi saint germain parce que saint
germain c'est prestigieux c'est saint
germain c'est le château parce que saint
germain il ya des perspectives
formidables aussi pour la transmission
de la télé et parce qu'on avait été
super bien accueilli en 2013 dans un
précédent départ de paris nice à saint
germain en laye a pas que le paris
saint-germain il ya énormément de
pratique sportive et donc c'est
important effectivement de montrer que
c'est une étape qui populaire le vélo
c'est très populaire
le lundi 11 mars à 12h35 le peloton
s'élancera des bréviaires pour une étape
de 173,5 kilomètres la petite commune de
1300 habitants située dans le sud des
yvelines deviendra la dix septième ville
du département à accueillir l'épreuve
c'est un événement historique à la fois
pour les bréviaires et pour moi
personnellement on va revoir toutes les
écoles voisines qui va venir participer
avec des départs en vélo donc et puis
tout le récit de toutes les communes
voisines
il ya saint germain cité royale célèbre
son château et puis il ya de l'autre
côté les bréviaires la plus petite
commune de paris nice 2010 at on en est
ravi mais les conditions s'y glisser ça
sont des grandes villes et des villes
moyennes et des petites communes les
1300 habitants des bréviaires pourront
notamment voir en action 23 équipes
cyclistes et notamment des stars de la
discipline comme le colombien nairo
quintana où les français romain bardet
ou arnaud démare